so other other than like work is there
anything fun that you're doing and or
looking forward to i guess um
doing after lockdown i mean yeah i mean
i can't wait to
you know hang out with friends and
and and that kind of thing and yeah
i love uh my wife is like one of the
most
talented people i've ever met and
watching her
perform live or you know watching her
work she's a dancer and choreographer
uh is just um absolutely breathtaking
and uh so i very much miss that
and you know i also canadian so i love
to like go to hockey games
oh my god that's so canadian that's
awesome so those are
you know uh you know those are
yeah things i look forward to and enjoy
so what you're
you're married to a dancer i i didn't
know so i mean has this upped your dance
game are you
do you know some new moves um well
i think what's so incredible about emma
uh is
she like we've done videos she's
included me in her work which is
incredibly humbling yeah and
she's just so incredible at
choreographing for
non-dancers you know so she makes me
look like i can
dance um and she also in the first
season of umbrella academy choreographed
this
beautiful dance scene they're in the
park oh yes
likes this very like long dance and
and you know and tom hadn't danced
that much before and she's so fun and
she's such a good
she's just so good at breaking all that
down and yeah
they make you look good man i know i've
had to do stuff i'm like nah
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going